welcome to this episode of uxd where
we'll show you three steps to make your
mobile applications awesome in this
episode we're going to be covering the
first step
I'm your host Nazmul Idris a developer
advocate on the Android team and I have
a very special guest with me today thank
you as well my name is Patrick larvae
I'm a researcher here at Google and I
have a lot to say about mobile ah you've
come to the right show the first thing
as a developer that you need to
understand about delivering a good user
experience that it's always about the
user and never about your application so
how many times have you seen
applications demand to be updated demand
to be rated demand new forms of payment
and demand your attention for a variety
of reasons now if you have a valid
business need to push out a new feature
or collect feedback from users you
especially need to be mindful of the
demands you're making on your users
attention so Patrick what is the right
way to demand user from the to demand
attention from the user well this is a
this is a really good question and
nothing substitutes for a good subtle
knowledge about how users are
interacting with your apps so if you
haven't done a little user research I
would suggest that you go do some before
you tackle this step but I think there's
a there's first of all there's a
distinction that we that we really need
to make there are times when you will
absolutely need your users attention
maybe have an update maybe there's
something that's absolutely critical
about continued use of the app you need
their attention there are other times
when you just want your users attention
it's really important to distinguish
these two because you don't want to wear
out your welcome you don't want to be
that app that's constantly making
demands on your one on your user whether
you want it or you just or whether you
need it or you just want it that makes
sense
uh-huh think about it if your app it's
just like the story of the boy who cried
wolf if you have an app and you're
constantly alerting your user about
things like did you or you're aware of
this new feature are you aware that we
have a new payment option are you aware
that there's a new kind of there's a new
we have some new colors for your fonts
right the time when you need that attend
that users attention because there's an
update there's a mission-critical update
that users going to ignore you that
makes sense so what are some things that
developers need to keep in mind when
they're asking their users to pay
attention
well let's sure first of all let's share
some examples about wanting versus
needing okay and I think the first thing
is it's really important to imagine that
your app doesn't just rely on the
phone's battery doesn't just rely on the
network connection doesn't just rely on
the computing capacity of that device it
also relies on another finite resource
which is your users attention let's say
that the app has just gone through an
update and that update is available to
be released um let's say in fact that
you have the most awesome Pizza ordering
app in the world I have I am a big fan
of that Pizza app because that delivers
the best pizza every time yeah think
about this if you have an update it's
something critical but let's say that
you're going to you're going to release
a new feature that allows the use of
text message to communicate between
driver and and the person ordering the
pizza are going to make sure that
delivery occurs on time call this is but
this requires a new consent from the
user because you're going to get the
user has to say yes I give you consent I
consent to the use of the the text
messaging app yeah
think about this when is the best time
to direct that user to the Play Store to
update that app and to provide new a new
consent is that when they're ordering
pizza very probably not the goal the the
goal here is to turn a demand I must
have consent in order to roll out this
new feature into an invitation no that
makes sense that makes sense
so so you might want to provide users
that have older versions of your
application with information with it
with a message inside of the application
that tells them there's a new version
that's coming and what benefits are
gonna get when they upgrade like in this
case the SMS feature so another thing
you might do is it if you have their
email address you might consider sending
them a short targeted message and again
only to folks that are using the old
versions of your application again to
give them a reason for why they need to
upgrade and the benefits that they're
gonna have when they actually perform
the upgrade that's right you want to
avoid the situation where the person
discovers a need for a critical update
at the moment when I'm really really
hungry and I want that pizza right
that's not the moment another another
limited resource to take into
consideration as we all know mobile
devices can only operate for so long
before they need to be recharged exactly
again we think of this as a constraint
but I think app developers should think
of this as an opportunity because this
provides you with an opportunity to
delight your user and it's an
opportunity to think about how you can
be how aware nosov the phone's
limitations can be a way that you can
work with your user rather than against
your users device make sense and again
speaking of finite resources battery
power is not the only one but there's
also network bandwidth there's network
availability the amount of memory on the
machine CPU utilization and also outside
of the the Machine the users attention
that's right I think it's really
important to be aware of the devices
state at moments when this is critical
to your app for example let's say you
are an app developer with the most
awesome cat video app ever you know the
chair user is queuing up some awesome
cat apps to watch but you're also aware
that users that users battery's down to
about 20% this is actually an
opportunity it sounds like this is gonna
be disaster for your app right no this
is this is a moment when you might
engage your user and say you know you
only have a current at the current rate
you're going this is only going to go on
for about five minutes might we switch
to a lower resolution might we queue
this for later there are lots of ways
that the apt of
who can say all right I'm aware of the
limitation of this device I'm going to
turn this into an opportunity for my
user to reengage rather than being the
app that's on when the device crashes no
that makes sense and as we know the
internet was invented to share cat
pictures and videos yes so now in
addition to battery another thing I mean
I'm actually Bob we'll talk about
battery one of the biggest drains on
batteries of GPS and I think it's
important for developers to keep in mind
how or when they should ask for a
high-resolution readings that consume a
lot of battery life versus when they can
do with course readings that don't
require a lot of battery life so for
example in that pizzeria application you
mentioned it might be appropriate at
different moments in time in the user
interaction for that pizza or during
application to ask for really high
resolution location information from the
GPS which might drain battery but it'll
be for a short period of time but fruit
for 90% of the time or even longer when
when the application is just sitting and
you know you haven't order a pizza there
is absolutely no reason for that thing
to to be to constantly ask for a high
resolution location updates which will
actually drain battery that's absolutely
right again you don't want to be the you
don't want to be the app that users
remember has the one that crashed their
device as the one that drained their
memory and this is what Windows was
saying it makes absolute sense nothing
irritates me more than when I see my GPS
turn on for absolutely no reason I have
5% battery left exactly remember that
what you want to look for opportunities
to let your user you also want to look
for opportunities to avoid the situation
where your app is involved in a crash
we're in a critical incident because it
doesn't matter if you're if the user was
only watching your cat video app for
five minutes before their device turned
off because it didn't have any more
battery right the users gonna remember
that app forever as the one that drained
my battery yeah exactly and even if it
was let's say that Pizza ordering
application that was at fault but
because the user perceived that that
Caturday application was the one that
was running when the battery went down
or that's that's all they're gonna
associate with that negative event
and and negative events stick with us
much more than positive events that's
right um here's a slightly different
take on this on this topic
there are times and this is a this is a
want there are times when you want to
get feedback from your users on how they
like your app or how the app is
performing or things that they they
think your app could do to be better
yeah
resist the temptation to ask your user
to rate or share like or otherwise
comment on the app at critical moments
let's go back to the pizza app for a
moment let's say you're you know that
that users selecting pizzas that
habitually selects pizza's orders pizzas
chooses favorites pizzas or who hasn't
delivered what's the right time what's
the seducible moment in the Parinda in
the usage lifecycle to reach out to that
user is it while he's ordering the pizza
is that while he's waiting for that
pizza to be delivered is it while he's
eating the pizza no this is again an
opportunity to turn a demand you need
good ratings right you need feedback
right but you want to turn that demand
into an invitation that means you know
when that pizza was delivered I would
say about starting about 60 minutes post
delivery that might be a decent time to
ask now that makes sense so in addition
to the three issues we talked about here
are some more best practices for
developers to think about when they're
when they're when they're actually
building their applications so coming
back to this issue of updates let's say
that you have updated your application
like the pizza ordering app and you need
more permissions but also as you've
updated the new version there's some
changes you've made to the backend and
you need to basically move users off of
the old back-end into the new back-end
so it's critical in this situation to to
actually make sure everybody has
migrated first before you turn off the
old web services that you have running
and that is actually something
developers are some application
developers don't take into account which
leads to a pretty bad user experience so
when users of the older applications go
to actually run them they just stop
working which is which is pretty awful
and so you have to keep in mind that it
takes time for updates to reach all the
users of your of your application so
make sure that you're checking to see
how many times
your old web services are being used and
so on before you actually decide to turn
them down
turn them off so another thing you might
want to do if it's a it's a really
critical upgrade and you can't really
wait I consider actually giving them an
explicit notification and and this way
you know at the very least when they
need it they won't be surprised that
it's not working anymore
because you've actually done the work
and you've actually notified them ahead
of time that they do need to perform
this update and you know this is that
this is really this is a this is also an
important topic for developers to
remember because notifications can be
super helpful there are lots of
opportunities to to inform and to engage
your users through notifications but
it's equally important that you don't
have to turn everything into a
notification so let's say you figured
you've met you you've done your research
you know how your users are engaging
with your pizza delivery app and you
know how to time that there's there are
good ways and less good ways to reach
out for that for that for that for the
rating or for some feedback you know you
know that you've done it the users had
the pizza and the pizzas been deliver
it's about 60 minutes that's the right
time to reach out to them that may also
be the right time to to give them other
notifications related to for example
changes in payment it might be an
opportunity other kinds of non-critical
changes in payment options changes in
selection of pizzas other kinds of
non-critical things you might consider
matching these intelligently and
delivering them at a time you know that
the user is in a state of mind to pay
attention to them you know that makes a
lot of sense so now I'm so I guess the
the most important thing is that the
timing is critical and that
understanding the difference between
what is engagement and what is an
interruption so like in this situation
like Mille I need to rate my pizza like
how the delivery was if I it's not that
the feature is a bad thing I do need
that feedback but the but the
presentation and and the timing of when
that feature is surfaced in the user
experience determines whether whether
the user actually is delighted by it or
actually is
is somewhat annoyed by it right we can
take an example of a notification that
can be either an interruption or an
opportunity to engage depending on its
timing right Pizza app let's say
something's fundamental is changing
about that Pizza app it's going to use
text messages to help locate where I am
and to communicate with a driver this is
a fundamental feature change it requires
the consent if I receive an email about
that and I know that before I go to to
order my next pizza that's it that's an
opportunity to engage your user and say
hey there's a key I know why you're
asking for consent exactly I know that
this benefits me awesome I can't wait to
order another pizza
if I find out that I have to update the
app and provide consent as I'm ordering
a pizza right that's now an interruption
very same notification in a context it
context determines whether that's an
interruption or an invitation to engage
that makes perfect sense
so so again as a developer then it's
critical for for us to stop blowing
foghorns in the users face for every
single event that that might happen so
so I've seen this in some applications
where notifications are used as a way to
debug things which is obviously a very
negative thing and I've also seen
persistent notifications for example in
Android used to basically notify the
user that an application is running or
something is connected those are really
bad and they need to go away right
that's right so back to the story about
the little boy who cried wolf or Chicken
Little who's telling us that the sky is
falling if I see that I have a
persistent notification from your app
right I'm going to think this is this
app is telling me the sky is falling
I'll fall for it once maybe I fall for
it twice I will not ever attend to that
again and the time when you have
something really really critical that
you need to tell me I'm not going to pay
attention that makes sense so batching
them intelligently finding the right
moment in the in the cycle of product
usage to reach your user when they're
when that user is likely open and able
to it to react yeah these are critical
aspects of mobile user experience yeah
no I think batching notifications is
kind of like a subtle distinction where
let's say that you have determined there
is a good case to to notify user for
example in Gmail I have an email I need
to know that I have any mail but let's
say I've received five emails like you
would get really annoying if I would get
five individual notifications for that
email for five different emails from
Gmail so
Gmail does is really nice which is it's
consolidate it actually consolidates
those five emails into one notification
and it says hey you have five emails
waiting and it does so for a different
account yeah I know that the people
watching this have had this experience I
order from a service that offers two-day
delivery and that service which a lot of
you use tells me every step of the way
about each of the items I don't really
want to know unless a there's a problem
or right it's about to arrive at my door
this is a great opportunity to batch and
I want to be the notification your app
wants to be the notification that I
received just before I'm delighted
because I've both in my package and I
got what I wanted exactly I think
there's another opportunity here
thinking about batching and timing and I
like to think of this as think before
you sing there's nothing more irritating
to me that what I'm again I'm on the bus
I'm usually on my way home I've got
about 20% battery on my phone and all of
a sudden all of my apps start syncing oh
yeah I can see the battery declining I
know that I'm not gonna able send on the
text message don't be that app the the
opportunity here is to use the the the
available data the data that's available
to your app to know a little bit about
how what your users patterns of activity
are by using what we think of as
attention profiling you can change how
your notifications occur and when
certain kinds of activities how certain
kinds of activities are best and carried
out no that makes sense so now this data
this attention profiling data like it
can be collected in a variety of ways
like we could actually have analytics
running or think they actually pieces of
code that are basically generating
analytics data that are running on the
device that then send all this
information to the server where it's
stored deeper analytics can be run and
then patterns can be predicted that
actually notified the application about
how a user actually interacts with it
now this data can then be used to
determine when scheduling operations
should happen between the applications
running on the device and and whatever
back-end it's connected connecting to
right
now alternatively if developers don't
have such sophisticated ways to make
this happen
there's a simpler solution which is
let's say you have an RSS reader
application and you have like hundreds
of feats that you subscribe to it would
be appropriate for that application to
ask you when you first run it how often
do you want to update do you want it to
happen for every single change in your
feats you will want it to happen once a
day twice a day once a week and so on so
there's high tech solutions to this and
low tech solutions but the important
thing is to set the appropriate
expectation and also determine like for
example what the user is expecting so
that you don't disappoint them even with
these constrained resources that we have
so now let's say that you do you do
collect a lot of really high-quality
attention profiling data you can also
consider providing this information to
all the connected devices that the the
user has so that means that if you have
a signed-in experience you can actually
take advantage of the fact that you know
something about how your users is using
their particular devices or your
applications on their device and then
you can use that data to drive the
experience on all them and all the
devices that are signed in to and you
could search for example with sign-in
with Google you can create a piece
ordering application that you run on
your phone and on your tablet and then
depending on how you use your tablet on
your phone
both those apps get smarter so that's
something which is I think a really big
opportunity that that developers can can
take advantage of and and these
analytics the analytics data that can
give you ideas of user how the user uses
the device when they use it where they
are when they're using it can give you
strong signals about when you need to
sync information we need to prefetch
information when you think that you
should cue notifications let's say
you're asleep and if the device knew
that then perhaps it would not send you
notifications while you're asleep right
that's a wake up though yeah exactly so
these kinds of things will allow you to
deliver delight to users of your
application so that's all we have time
for in today's episode stay tuned for
the next tool or we'll give you the
other two steps in making your
applications awesome and thank you so
much Patrick thank you and thank you for
your attention
cool